mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour
deux faits principaux marquent
l'actualité ce matin pour l'étranger
toujours le proche orient et la france
vient de faire connaître sa réponse à la
note soviétique portant sur le conflit
israélo arabe tandis que sur le plan
militaire des nageurs de combat
égyptiens se sont attaqués avec succès à
deux navires israéliens dans le port
d'eilat en france à nanterre ce poursuit
le congrès du parti communiste le 19e et
ce matin on attendait avec intérêt la
déclaration de monsieur roger garaudy le
contestataire numéro un du parti
communiste et suppute un discours
violent passionnés accueilli à nanterre
dans un silence glacial innovation ou
risques d'inondations dans l'est le jura
et le bassin parisien pour l'information
générale voilà l'essentiel de
l'actualité de ce matin mais revenons au
problème du proche orient est d'abord
l'aspect diplomatique ce matin ce matin
à moscou
les trois ambassadeurs occidentaux ont
remis la réponse de leur pays au message
du président koshiki dernière réponse
être rendu public est bien celle de la
france daniel cazals oui et c'est
monsieur roger ses looks et
l'ambassadeur de france en union
soviétique qui a transmis la réponse de
la france a répondu président pompidou
au message du président que si guînes
il faut dit en substance le président de
la république française il faut rétablir
le cessez-le feu
seuls les casques bleus sont capables de
faire respecter ce cessez le feu
il faut donc que les casques bleus
retourne au moyen-orient voilà quand la
réponse française
la réponse britannique a été apportée
elle aussi au kremlin ce matin le
premier ministre monsieur wilson estime
qu'il faut revenir au cessez-le-feu mais
qu'il faut aussi se mettre d'accord sur
un embargo généralisée sur les
livraisons d'armes au moyen-orient ai
dit monsieur wilson si on ne peut pas
mettre se mettre d'accord sur cet
embargo généralisée il faut au moins
limiter la livraison d'armes au proche
orient
enfin la troisième réponse est la
réponse américaine une réponse que l'on
connaît déjà le président nixon suggère
propose un embargo généralisée et
suggère que moscou invite le caire à
respecter le cessez-le-feu
oui et sur le plan militaire on peut
dire que l' escalade continue puisque ce
matin ce sont les égyptiens
tu relances et le premier coup en effet
des hommes grenouilles enfin plutôt des
nageurs de combat ont attaqué avec
succès des navires israéliens dans le
port même d'eilat
oui ces nageurs de combat sont allés
poser des mines sous deux navires de
guerre israéliens l'un de ses navires de
guerre a coulé et l'autre a été
endommagé c'est la deuxième fois
d'ailleurs en quelques mois que des
hommes grenouilles des nageurs de combat
égyptien s'introduisent dans le port
d'eilat
ce sabotage n'a cependant fait aucune
victime
en revanche une embuscade tendue à une
patrouille israélienne par un commando
égyptien a été particulièrement
meurtrière selon tel aviv quatre soldats
israéliens et cinq soldats égyptiens ont
été tués dans cet accrochage
oui demain vous le savez il ya ce qu'on
appelle un petit somme est un petit
sommet au caire
mais on remarque l'absence de la libye à
cette réunion
la libye ne participera pas à ce sommet
car elle ne se trouve pas directement
engagées sur le champ de bataille
or ce sommet doit réunir demain au caire
les chefs d'état des pays qui sont
directement engagés dans le conflit du
moyen-orient
c'est à dire l'egypte la syrie la
jordanie le soudan un autre pays sera
représenté il s'agit de l'irak dont des
unités sont stationnés en jordanie
les participants à ce sommet seront bien
entendu le point de la situation mais il
est probable aussi qu'ils étudieront les
trois réponses occidentale transmise ce
matin au créneau en bref maintenant
d'autres nouvelles internationales tout
d'abord une affaire d'espionnage dont
l'origine dès hier à pouvoir enfin c'est
la suisse je crois depuis la suisse on
apprend qu'il ya une affaire
d'espionnage qui vient d'éclater
laquelle oui bien laquelle je ne saurais
pas vous dire exactement car les
autorités suisses sont très peu bavarde
tout ce que l'on sait c'est qu'un
employé des amateurs des abattoirs de
lausanne a été arrêté il est soupçonné
d'appartenir au réseau d'espionnage
soviétique en europe occidentale
on sait également que deux
fonctionnaires soviétiques seraient
impliqués dans cette affaire mais enfin
il faudra attendre un petit peu pour en
connaître les développements sud-vietnam
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il y à la fête
du têt la trêve de la fête du têt qui le
nouvel an donc au sud vietnam
mais on a quand même noter comme chaque
année il faut le constater comme chaque
année à pareille époque on a noté une
série d'accrochages
malgré tout ce fut une trêve
une vraie trêve bien qu'un simulacre de
paix tous les vietnamiens ceux du sud
comme ceux du nord et avec eux tous les
chinois de canton à pékin ont célébré
hier la fête la plus traditionnelle est
la plus sacrée de l'année le nouvel an
du calendrier lunaire alors toutes les
familles se réunissent pour rendre
hommage à la mémoire des ancêtres
disparus et au vietnam bien entendu pour
prier pour la paix l'extrême orient est
entré hier dans l'année du chien après
avoir bruyamment dit adieu à l'année du
coq l'année du chien sera telle celle de
la paix en tout cas le président sud
vietnamien pieux dans son message de
nouvel an s'est déclaré optimiste mais
il n'a pas promis de victoire pour cette
année depuis quelques heures la trêve du
côté américain et sud vietnamien est
terminée elle n'aura duré que 24 heures
les troupes du fn elle observe quant à
elle une trêve de quatre jours et ne
reprendront leur opération qu'à partir
de lundi matin
cette trêve du nouvel an a été marquée
par une cinquantaine d'incidents graves
mais les américains ne parlent pas de
violation de la trêve il y a donc pu
aussi trêve dans l'escaladé verbale ce
qui semble d'ailleurs faire partie de la
politique des états unis visant à la
vietnamisation du coffre vietnamisation
qui ne signifie pas nécessairement la
fin de la guerre hanoi en tout cas parle
toujours de plusieurs années de guerre
et d'austérité
affaire française maintenant c'est donc
ce matin à nanterre que monsieur roger
garaudy devait en quelque sorte
présenter sa défense devant ses
camarades du parti réunis pour leur 19e
concret et ces jours derniers
rappelez-vous de nombreux délégués dont
monsieur marchait avait lancé de
violentes attaques contre l'écrivain
communiste roger garaudy
oui ce matin encore monsieur garaudy a
fait l'objet de nouvelles critiques
essais critiques émanant cette fois de
monsieur etienne fra jean qui est le
directeur de l'humanité qui est membre
du comité central du parti communiste
monsieur phal jours a accusé monsieur
garaudy de brouiller les objectifs de la
politique du parti et monsieur vachon a
notamment déclaré je cite roger garaudy
là je pense qu'on peut noter qu'il ne
s'agit pas on n'appelle pas le camarade
gaudi mais on dit roger garaudy roger
garaudy donc nous sommes de nous
désolidariser du parti communiste
soviétique sous couleur de gagner la
confiance de démocrates nos communistes
notre parti continuera au contraire à
dénoncer tout antisoviétique mme vien de
toute façon roger garaudy à 8 c 15
minutes réglementaires pour défendre ses
thèses
et comme on le pense est loin de faire
amende honorable
son discours a pris parfois les allures
de véritable réquisitoire mais pour
faire le point nous appelons maintenant
sur place à nanterre en direct
henri-françois de virieu oui nous avons
vécu ce matin les instants assez
dramatique dans cette salle que vous
voyez là était maintenant désertes car
les congressistes sont partis déjeuner
vous l'avez dit roger roger garaudy le
philosophe contestataires en lutte avec
son parti depuis maintenant deux ans
était venu présenter sa défense face à
une salle dans laquelle et cela ils le
savaient ils ne comptaient que très peu
d'amis on savait que roger hoareau de
garaudy voulait s'expliquer mais on
ignorait ce qu'il disait ce qu'il dirait
certains pensaient ici parmi les
militants qu'il ferait son autocritique
en fait ils auront été déçus car pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du parti
communiste français
un dirigeant a été autorisé à prendre la
parole et il la prit d'ailleurs plus
longuement que les 15 minutes dont vous
venez de parler mais ce n'était pas pour
reconnaître s'il tonne et pendant
tahitienne fajon roger garaudy s'est
battu pied à pied
il est monté à la tribune il a parlé il
est redescendu tribune dans un silence
absolument glacial
une seule fois il a été sifflé
lorsqu'après avoir dit l'anti soviétisme
est un crime contre la france et contre
la paix il a ajouté ce qui nourrit cet
anti communisme c'est les actes par
lesquels on viole les principes du parti
et visant l'urss il a ajouté que dire
d'un pays qui après avoir divisé le
parti de mme analystes les hausses
construit des centrales électriques pour
ses bourreaux les fascistes gré et il a
conclu roger garaudy les méthodes du
parti seront un jour changer même si
aujourd'hui on écarte quelques-uns de
ceux qui posent les problèmes vous
donneront ce soir à 19h45 et en images
des extraits plus long des travaux de ce
convoi eh bien merci françois henri de
virieu depuis quelques jours il semble
qu'une nouvelle forme de contestation se
manifestent en france
de plus en plus fréquemment l'action
directe de petit commando avant même de
rechercher le dialogue et c'est le cas
par exemple survenu hier soir au métro
boulogne billancourt
oui la contestation était souterrain de
la barre groupe de gauchistes à
manifester contre les augmentations de
tarifs de la ratp
le slogan vous le connaissez c'est
toujours le même il est célèbre
le gouvernement ne nous transporte pas
ils nous roulent il ya eu quelques
accrochages huit employés de la ratp ont
été contusionnées et ce matin les
syndicats cgt et cfdt de la ratp
protestent contre ces violences condamne
leurs auteurs tout en s'élevant
d'ailleurs contre les augmentations de
tarifs de la ratp à rennes à rennes des
peines allant de huit ans de huit mois à
1 an de prison ferme ont été demandées
contre trois jeunes militaires jugés par
le tribunal des forces armées ces trois
militaires sont inculpé d'incitation de
militaires à commettre des actes
contraires à la discipline
ils ont reconnu avoir distribué des
tracts et des journaux antimilitariste
et bien informations générales
maintenant le mauvais temps le mauvais
temps c'est à dire la pluie et le
radoucissement relatif de la température
ont provoqué des inondations qui
menacent non seulement le bassin
parisien
mais encore et surtout l'est de la
france le jura et le bar
le dégel marié à la pluie de phénomènes
qui s'entendent parfaitement pour faire
déborder les rivières alsaciennes
ici le rhin rohrschollen tout pas de
strasbourg depuis deux jours le niveau
des zones est cessait de monter le
mouvement s'est accéléré aujourd'hui
pour atteindre la côte d' alerte de 5 m
un accident d'ailleurs assez
spectaculaire s'est produit cette nuit à
la hauteur de drusenheim ou le pont bac
qui relie la france à l'allemagne a été
littéralement éperonné par une péniche
hollande dans de nombreux secteurs près
ces chemins sont recouverts comme ici
entre heurter gates of time ou lazare on
est sorti de son lit
quelques habitations bien sûr sont
cernées par les eaux mais l'on ne
déplore aucun dégât important déjà la
nationale 63 aux environs de brumath et
recouverte par 10 cm pour l'instant la
circulation n'est pas interrompue
quant aux reins il n'est pas épargné lui
non plus les pêcheurs ne reconnaissent
plus lille ce cours d'eau habituellement
tranquille qui est devenu sauvage et
roule à présent une eau lourde et salle
tout chargé de sable et de boue à colmar
le long de la lors les jardins sont sous
les eaux sur la départementale 3 entre
ostheim lilas aux au compte de maison
rouge
la route est coupée par les eaux tandis
que les plaines sont inonde aillleurs
zane lille et la flèche de menaces le
village dans l'ensemble pourtant de la
région ces mouvements de crue on peut
l'affirmer ce matin sont tout de même en
légère régression
à condition toutefois que de nouvelles
pluies ne fassent leur apparition ces
prochaines 24 heures
ledoux et ses affluents sont en crue à
ornans ville natale du peintre courbet
lahlou menace dangereusement ces
riverains et la cote d' alerte était
hier tout près d'être atteinte
heureusement la température a baissé
hier et cette nuit dans le jura la fonte
des neiges a cessé et on enregistre
aujourd'hui une légère décrue sur la
loue mais à besançon le doubs et étals
et les bas quartiers sont toujours
inondées la rivière envahi les prairies
les écluses sont submergés et bien
entendu toute ta vie gassion est rendue
impossible
les promenades riveraines sont
transformées en pièces d'eau les
pompiers de besançon ont dû intervenir à
plusieurs reprises hier la distribution
du courant électrique a été interrompue
dans plusieurs quartiers de la ville
seuls les pêcheurs ont largement profité
de cette circonstance exceptionnelle
notons que la circulation routière n'est
pas perturbée sauf près de
saint-hippolyte aux deux piles du pont
de glaire se sont effondrés sur la route
eh bien à paris la seine monte aussi
beaucoup plus en droit mais en tout cas
la circulation sur les quais rive gauche
a été interrompu ce matin toute façon
pour la première fois le zouave du pont
de l'alma le célèbre zouaves n'aura plus
les pieds dans l'eau puisque vous savez
que en ce moment il est à quai au sec
disons en réfection il s'est enfin posé
il
c'est le fameux boeing 747 cet avion
géant de 350 places et plus quelquefois
le 747 est arrivé hier à orly et c'est
cet après midi à 13h30 qu'il doit
effectuer son premier vol de
démonstration réservé aux officiels et
aux journalistes français ce soir à 20h
nous verrons de plus près ce du budget
l'un des plus grands avions commerciaux
construits dans le monde et nous allons
maintenant rejoindre un miraculé de la
route en effet hier soir sur la ligne
paris strasbourg
une voiture a dérapé sur un passage à
niveau
elle y rester et l'express paris chalon
survenait quelques instants plus tard un
reportage de geek laisse ce tas de
ferraille c'est tout ce qui reste d'une
simca 1000 la locomotive l'accueillît de
plein fouet et l'a traînée sur 420
mètres arrachant au passage les boîtes
sélectives du circuit de signalisation
de la sncf seul le volant curieusement
est intacte par chance le conducteur et
son passager avait eu le temps de sauter
juste avant l'arrivée du train lancé à
plus de 100 à l'heure dans une ligne
droite
j'y passais sur le passage à niveau j'ai
glissé seul la voiture arrière elle a
glissé mais rouen dérapé sur le sur la
valeur avait dit que vous êtes retrouvé
donc en travers de la voie pdg des bus
bloqués ici il n'avait pas pu redémarrer
le moteur n'était pas arrêtée j'ai
essayé j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
et vous avez revu le train arrivait eh
bien le
le chef de carrière à la barre hier les
évacuer et bien ce monsieur peut
remercier le garde barrière pour dégager
la voie
les gendarmes les employés de la sncf
ont passé autour des débris de la
voiture des cordages
ils ont fixé au rail puis on a fait
venir une autre locomotive
car les freins de la notice de l'express
paris chalon s'était bloquée dans la
commune
l'opération menée sous une petite pluie
fine et glacées a demandé plus de deux
heures le train enfin reculait en
portant comme une sorte de trophée est
dérisoire une portière qui était resté
accroché
il n'y avait plus qu'à faire basculer la
carcasse sur le bas coûts cet accident a
naturellement provoqué le gros retards
sur la ligne paris strasbourg
bien je vous parlais de miracle je crois
que le mot n'est quand même pas trop
fort sport maintenant quelques nouvelles
tout d'abord athlétisme les championnats
de france en salle débuteront ce soir à
l'institut national des sports avec pour
principale attraction dix ans le 6 100 m
féminin qui opposera une nouvelle fois
nicole duclos et colette besson
on note également la rentrée de bambou
sur 100 m en basket et bien rappelons
l'excellent résultat obtenu hier soir à
belgrade par villeurbanne contre le
champion de yougoslavie
battu d'un tout point enfin disons d'un
point seulement 76 à 75 patinage enfin
hier soir oui à leningrad le premier
titre européen a été décerné dans la
catégorie réservée aux couples et ce
sont les soviétiques que nous voyons ici
rosina oulianov qui l'ont emporté
aujourd'hui patrick paiera entre en lice
dans les figures imposées où il tentera
de prendre quelques points aux
tchécoslovaque né paie là qui reste
quand même favori pour le titre
voilà et bien une hirondelle on le dit
souvent ne fait pas le printemps je
crois pas nier le casal que nous allons
maintenant vous allez commenter un sujet
sur les oiseaux migrateurs est ce que ça
nous annonce ou moins la fin de ce
mauvais temps ou pas spécialement parce
que nous sommes encore au coeur de
l'hiver mais le propos de ce sujet c'est
d'intérêt l'attention un petit peu sûre
si vous voulez les centres d'hébergement
c'est un mot peut-être un peu fort mais
enfin disons les mesures pour accueillir
ces oiseaux migrateurs qui d'année en
année sont de moins en moins nombreux
car les espèces tendent à disparaître
bien je pense que nous devons maintenant
voir
mi décembre à mi janvier cet homme
entreprend la tournée des étangs et déco
il est chargé du comptage et de la
reconnaissance des oiseaux migrateurs
inlassablement ils fouillent la surface
des eaux à la recherche des oiseaux
aquatiques qui ont quitté les pays
froids pour des régions plus clémentes
ces oiseaux venus du froid sont ici la
cible de chasseurs pacifique
ces chasseurs d'image ont pour seul but
de les photographier pour ensuite les
identifier et dans la mesure du possible
participer à leur protection
ne vous y trompez pas ces migrateurs ne
sont pas aussi nombreux que leurs vols
groupés pourrait le laisser croire
s'il ya encore 350 à 400 milles canard
certaines espèces sont en voie de
disparition
les oies cendrées les cygnes sauvages
étaient quelques milliers il ya 50 ans
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que
quelques centaines dans dix ans ils
auront disparu si rien n'est tenté pour
les sauver
la côte où s'arrête ces migrateurs leur
offre l'algue dont ils ont besoin pour
se nourrir de cet endroit que les cygnes
sauvages ont choisi pour leurs quartiers
d'hiver
il est possible de faire un havre de
paix
et des réserves c'est le voeu que
forment ce qui se consacre à la
protection des oiseaux migrateurs
c'est aussi le seul moyen d'éviter que
dans quelques années le vol majestueux
des cygnes sauvages ne soit plus qu'un
vague souvenir
et bien sauf informations de dernière
minute daniel cazals et moi même vous
souhaitons un bon après midi et nous
retrouvons maintenant henri tisot